[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 5 mai c'est la
région ile de france avec l'association
âtre axis vient de lancer l'appel à
projets innovants
l'expérimentation tech et ce coup
objectif développer des solutions
innovantes pour les pompiers
le dispositif a été présenté jeudi 29
avril au centre de secours de saint
germain en laye l'actualité c'est
également la célébration du bicentenaire
de la mort de napoléon bonaparte
l'empereur est mort le 5 mai 1821
l'occasion de présenter la collection
napoléonienne du château de versailles
notre invité à ce sujet valérie bas l'ex
auteur et ancien membre correspondante
de la fondation napoléon
enfin d'édition un défi sportif à
joueurs qu'on chantera un habitant on va
faire le tour de la corse en vélo
électrique
en plus d'être sportif le défi sera
aussi solidaire mathieu chance qu'on
veut récolter des dons pour l'omd 6 ans
atteinte du syndrome de rett
[Musique]
avant cela une nouvelle maison médicale
va bientôt voir le jour à plaisir le
président sortant candidat à sa
réélection du département des yvelines
s'est rendue sur place la semaine
dernière
l'occasion de revenir sur l'objectif du
projet lutter contre la désertification
médicale du territoire plaisir n'est
fiable pas justement à cette
désertification donc en sus et plaisir
on a on n'a pas suffisamment de médecins
même si vous comme vous le dites il ya
il ya bien sûr un hôpital mais l'hôpital
l'hôpital avant l'offre proposée par
l'hôpital aujourd'hui ne couvrent pas
les besoins du territoire de plaisir et
bien sûr là on a besoin d'une maison
médicale pour faire venir des médecins
les premiers médecins de la ruche sont
accueillis par l'hôpital
en attendant la livraison du site en
2023 pour les encourager à s'installer
dans les futurs locaux une prime a été
voté par la commune à hauteur de 10000
europhobe direction saint germain en
laye à présent où les pompiers des
yvelines souhaite développer des
solutions innovantes dans leur activité
c'était l'objet du lancement de l'appel
à projets innovants expérimentation tech
et secours en collaboration avec la
région ile de france
la vice présidente en charge du
développement économique alexandra du
blanche a présenté ce dispositif jeudi
29 avril au centre de secours de saint
germain en est les détails de nicolas
landry
[Applaudissements]
un drone pour faciliter leur activité
c'est l'exemple d'une innovation
utilisée par les pompiers des yvelines
des outils de plus en plus présents dans
leurs missions essentielles sauver des
vies l'innovation doit nous permettre de
nous améliorer dans cette mission doit
nous permettre d'être encore meilleur
plus performants pour effectivement
continuer à sauver beaucoup plus de vies
dans des conditions à la fois beaucoup
plus sécure pour les victimes
et puis aussi pour les savoirs continuer
soir autre exemple d'innovation ce
système de sécurisation de zones
d'accidents initié avec une entreprise
située en région auvergne rhône-alpes
pour sécuriser notre zone on dispose des
cônes pour interdire la circulation à
l'arrière de ce véhicule bélier a bardé
du moment où un véhicule rentre dans la
zone donne instantanément le flash blanc
clignote cinq fois et le hand devant
averti tous les intervenants
pour faciliter le développement de
solutions innovantes la région ile de
france avec l'association âtre axis ont
lancé l'appel à projet in over jusqu'à
500 mille euros de subventions et 3
millions d'euros d'avancés remboursables
les entreprises peuvent candidater pour
être sélectionnés d'ici au mois de
juillet nos pompiers sont confrontés de
plus en plus de défis ils doivent aussi
se modernise et innover le font déjà
mais n'ont parfois pas toujours accès à
tous le vivier innovant d'entreprises de
la région ile de france et c'est là où
nous on peut intervenir au niveau de la
région les aider à avoir accès à cette
innovation les startups devront tenter
de relever cinq défis comme
l'optimisation de la prise en charge
hospitalière des victimes le renfort de
la sécurité des pompiers ou encore la
sensibilisation aux gestes de premiers
secours début des expérimentations en
septembre prochain dans l'actualité
également un hommage sera rendu demain
jeudi 6 mai à justin almeida ce jeune
sapeur-pompier volontaire de 19 ans
décédé dans un accident de la route
vendredi 30 avril dernier à son chant le
jeune homme se rendait à moto à
rambouillet lorsqu en doublant un bus il
a été percuté par une camionnette
il devait assurer le dispositif de
sécurité lors de l'hommage national
rendu à stéphanie m'enfermer la
policière assassiné par un terroriste
une semaine plus tôt dimanche 2 mai est
déjà à des pompiers des motards mais
aussi des membres de l'association une
rose un espoir dont il était adhérent
lui ont rendu hommage en déposant des
fleurs là où a eu lieu l'accident ce
jeudi 6 mai la caserne des pompiers de
rambouillet où il travaillait lui rendra
également hommage lors d'une cérémonie
protocolaire avec remise de décorations
une cagnotte litchi a également été
ouverte par sa famille la somme récoltée
sera réparti entre les trois
associations dont il contribuait
l'unicef dont il était ambassadeur une
rose un espoir qui lutte contre le
cancer est l'oeuvre des pupilles
orphelins et fondante reine des sapeurs
pompiers
de l'histoire avec un grand h à présente
cette année est principalement
aujourd'hui nous célébrons le
bicentenaire de la mort de napoléon
bonaparte l'empereur est mort le 5 mai
1821 à s'en tenait à sainte-hélène
pardon soit il y a deux cents ans
aujourd'hui à cette occasion et avant de
recevoir notre invité à ce sujet je vous
laisse découvrir la collection
napoléonienne du château de versailles
un reportage de nicolas landry et
justine brasil
c'est l'une des plus importantes
collections napoléonienne le château de
versailles expose peintures et
sculptures des avoirs représentant
l'empereur les événements de son époque
ses grandes victoires comme celle du
pont d'arcole de marengo ou encore
d'austerlitz mais aussi des
personnalités de son entourage des
offres qui ont toutes été pratiquement
pour l'essentiel commandé par napoléon
pour ces pour sa propre communication et
qui ont été rassemblés ici à versailles
par louis-philippe quand il a créé ces
galeries historique de versailles dans
les années 1830
parmi les oeuvres exposées bonaparte au
pont d'arcole napoléon passant le grand
st bernard ou encore le tableau du sacre
une oeuvre emblématique du premier
empire
réalisé par david ce tableau évidemment
qui est une recomposition d'une scène
historique puisque l'artiste a ouvert le
la scène est finalement sur le devant
que le spectateur participe de l'action
du tableau vraiment on a l'impression
d'être vraiment dans le dans le public
de participer en fait à cet événement du
sacre certains artistes de l'entourage
de david lui ont suggéré de représenter
l'empereur couronnant l'impératrice qui
était une
un geste plus auguste et qui avait plus
de plus de- allure pour le tableau
[Musique]
premier consul stratège est général dans
les armées de la république
l'empereur controversé a marqué
l'histoire de france il laisse en
héritage plusieurs institutions un
système administratif en particulier sur
lequel nous vivons encore beaucoup
aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui la
structure de l'état français est
complètement un héritage de l'époque de
napoléon avec la création de certaines
institutions comme le conseil d'état la
banque de france la préfecture les
lycées la collection napoléonienne
château de versailles recense 400
tableaux et 200 sculptures pour
continuer à parler de ce bicentenaire de
la mort de napoléon bonaparte nous
accueillons en visioconférence avec nos
vallées rival ex bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes auteur de deux livres sur
l'empereur mais également une ancienne
membre correspondante de la fondation
napoléon à paris alors pour ce
bicentenaire une cérémonie officielle
était organisée aujourd'hui ce 5 mai le
président de la république a prononcé un
discours à l'institut de france puis est
allé déposer une gerbe au pied de son
tombeau aux invalides
cette cérémonie s'est lié notamment au
fait que napoléon a mis en place un
certain nombre d'institutions modernes
n'est ce pas
or ben oui on vit beaucoup dessus je
suis pas sûr tous les gens connaissent
toutes les institutions sur lesquels on
villes moyennes que j'aime a rappelé
tout simplement c'est par exemple outre
le code civil et tout le reste c'est
aussi la numérotation pairs et impairs
des rues avant il y avait des rues à 500
600 numéros il fallait indiquer la
boucherie en face le barbie à côté
c'était pas simple et puis je le
rappelle il a aussi inventé le
baccalauréat les préfectures le code
civil ou encore les chambres de commerce
et évidemment la liste n'est pas
exhaustive et fait aussi un grand
stratège napoléon bonaparte il a mené de
grandes batailles j'en suis de
quelques-unes le pont d'arcole marengo
ou encore austerlitz n'est ce pas un
valérie molex vers l'iss le friyed
landes wagram qui est l'une des plus
célèbres est plus reconnu
après on peut lui reprocher d'être trop
de batailles mais finalement il faut
commémorer parce que c'est rappeler le
souvenir aussi d'une époque glorieuse
qui domine
europe et dans laquelle répondait les
lumières aussi il faut pas oublier
s'arrête en avez lumière à travers les
pays occupés on va dire entre guillemets
eu l'idée de liberté d'égalité de
progrès par les élites mondiales par les
français c'est plus beaucoup le cas
aujourd'hui part peut-être la reine
d'angleterre alors époque en effet
glorieuse sur le plan stratégique
glorieux sur les institutions qu'il a pu
mettre en place mais aussi controversé
cet anniversaire a ravivé notamment la
controverse autour du fait de fait qu'il
est rétabli l'esclavagé en 1802 ou
encore de son énorme bilan humain vous
l'avez évoqué lors de ses campagnes
militaires
je vais citer emmanuel macron commémorer
le bicentenaire sans le célébrer ce sont
ses mots
selon vous aujourd'hui cette cérémonie
officielle est ce que c'est un événement
ce bicentenaire qu'il fallait célébrer
aller à la célébration c'est compliqué
parce que il y aura même beaucoup de
polémiques et je pense qu'on a assez de
sujets de division aujourd'hui avec le
virus et tout ce qui se passe donc la
commémoration elle était parfaite
j'ai écouté le discours d' emmanuel
macron bas il était sobre comme il
l'avait promis
voilà il a dénoncé des faits il faut
regarder l'histoire en face on peut pas
la réécrire de toute façon donc il faut
assumer tout justement parlant
d'histoire et ce qui a beaucoup de
présidents qui ont commémoré ses
anniversaires liés en tout cas elle en
prendra pauline bonaparte alors il ya eu
en 1921 les tout premiers prêts et
chapeau et président qui étaient là pour
le centenaire de sa mort est ensuite bon
il ya eu notamment monsieur conquis
d'eau qui a vraiment lui célébré au sens
où on l'entend vraiment avec des fêtes
enfin des choses comme ça mais c'était
plutôt pour la naissance de l'empereur à
ce que ça change quelque chose dont ont
été célébrés napoléon de toute façon
alors comme on le voit vous connaissez
bien l'histoire de l'empereur je le
rappelle vous êtes passionné histoire
particulièrement de napoléon de cette
époque
comment cette passion est elle venue
valérie va l'ex tout simplement parce
que je suis né dans les yvelines et on
n'habitait pas très loin de la malmaison
c'était la promenade dominicale dans les
jardins sont là c'était pas payant on y
allait facilement qu'ils étaient
fascinés notamment par joséphine et de
joséphine sans napoléon c'était
difficile il n'y avait qu'un pas donc il
est franchie
viola comme ça m'est arrivé behar
question valérie vallaeys comme j'ai dit
vous êtes auteur de deux romans dont
l'histoire se passe au temps de napoléon
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à écrire en
vous inspirant de cette époque
et puis est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter un petit peu ce que vous
racontez dans ses livres alors mes
livres sont tout à fait tout à fait
poste napoléonien c'est à dire sans 1815
après waterloo
donc je ne suis pas en pleine époque
napoléonienne en trainde d'encenser
l'empereur et tout le reste je peux
raconter l'histoire d'un soldat qui a
été gravement blessé et qui est fidèle
aux valeurs comme je le rappelais tout à
l'heure de lumière philosophique qu'il
était répandue à travers les pays et
donc ça va raconter son histoire parce
qu'après ils sont persécutés ya une
véritable chasse aux sorcières qui est
fait après 1815 par les royalistes
après les anciens de la grande armée et
notamment l'état major de napoléon et
c'est ça que je raconte dans les deux
livres en parlant notamment aussi des
progrès qui ont été faits sur les champs
de bataille même si son épouvantable à
dire avec l'arrêt le chirurgien la
grande armée ayant 14 ce sera pareil on
va faire des progrès spectaculaires avec
les épouvantables blessures
malheureusement les champs de bataille
sont des viviers pour la médecine
notamment la médecine de catastrophe
merci valérie valin ex d'avoir été avec
nous sur ce plateau pour 7,8 journal et
évidemment on retiendra un napoléon
bonaparte personnage historique
important mais évidemment controversé
et justement après napoléon passons à la
préhistoire une exposition a pris place
au domaine de saint germain en laye la
préhistoire en bande dessinée présente
les planches du dessinateur eric lebrun
si l'exposition était initialement prévu
pour les salles du musée
à cause de la crise sanitaire elle a été
montée en extérieur découverte avec
justin brazy la préhistoire en bande
dessinée 45 panneaux ont été installés
au coeur du domaine de saint germain en
laye objectif de l'exposition montré un
panorama de l'art préhistorique
depuis les origines aux alentours de -40
milan jusqu'à la fin du paléolithique
aux alentours de dix mille ans de moins
dix mille ans au moment où le climat se
réchauffe les panneaux mettent en avant
les planches du dessinateur eric lebrun
l'exposition est basé sur les trois
volumes 2 bd l'art préhistorique en
bande dessinée
vous avez ces planches de dessins issus
des trois des trois bd qu'il a réalisé
lors de la prise de la préhistoire et au
verso se trouve en fait une autre bd
dont il est scénariste
les planches sont en lien avec des
objets appartenant aux collections
préhistoriques du musée d'archéologie
nationale des collections pour l'heure
visible en ligne grâce à des qr codes
comme par exemple les venus nous voyons
de sa tête féminine donc ils
représentent des femmes enceintes qui
ont été trouvés en dordogne une à tursac
et une à sireuil que l'on peut bien sûr
retrouver dans les vitrines du musée
dans la galerie du paléolithique
et puis il ya aussi une petite dame qui
est très connu qu'on appelle la dame à
la capuche
l'exposition s'adresse à tout public une
phase est prévue pour les enfants des
planches sans paroles c'est l'histoire
d'un petit enfant de cro magnon qui
découvre là qu'ils découvrent l'art en
fête en mettant ses mains dans la boue
en laissant des traces derrière lui
voilà et de l'autre côté donc c'est un
petit peu plus pour les parents entre
guillemets
donc ça raconte vraiment les différentes
périodes de la préhistoire
une exposition proposée jusqu'à mi
septembre
elle est accessible à tous gratuitement
depuis 2018 l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines observe une
croissance importante des foyers de
chenilles processionnaires du chêne sur
l'ensemble de son territoire
cette chenille est inscrite dans une
liste d'organismes vivants classés
nuisibles et présente un risque
sanitaire pour les individus et animaux
il pour faire face à cette prolifération
l'agglomération met en place différents
moyens de lutte les précisions de joe
sakal astrid bergère et bérangère bongo
depuis 2010 9 saint quentin en yvelines
met en place des traitements pour lutter
contre la prolifération des foyers de
chenilles processionnaires des chaînes
le plus utilisé est le biologique pour
2021 il se déroule depuis le 12 avril et
jusqu'au 31 mai il s'agit de la
pulvérisation d'une bouillie avec une
basse il
c'est une bactérie présente à l'état
naturel on pulvérise cette base il sur
les sur le feuillage les chenilles qui
sont défoliatrices viennent manger les
feuilles et à gérer cette bactérie
cette bactérie produit une enzyme qui va
dégrader
l'appareil digestif des génies à et
provoqué leur lot de traitement par seat
ont lieu à trois ou quatre semaines
d'écart l'agglomération ne peut pas agir
sur l'entièreté de son domaine elle
sélectionne donc les cycliques plus à
risque
on priorise des sites en fonction de la
fréquentation piétonne du docteur
festation et du site en particulier la
chenilles processionnaires du chêne
présente un risque sanitaire pour les
individus qui peuvent avoir des
démangeaisons et des réactions cutanées
un risque dû aux poils urticants présent
sur le nuisible
les personnes les plus à risque ce sont
les très jeunes enfants les personnes
âgées et les personnes qui ont des
problèmes de maladies respiratoires les
animaux domestiques notamment les chiens
ou les où les ruminants peuvent être
beaucoup plus embêté ils vont pouvoir
avoir des conséquences bien plus graves
allant de l'ablation de la langue
jusqu'au décès dans certains cas
l'agencé régionale de santé conseille
tout de même aux personnes ayant été en
contact avec les chenilles
processionnaires de se rapprocher de
leur médecin traitant pour refermer
cette édition à jouarre pontchartrain un
habitant a décidé de se lancer un défi
faire le tour de la corse à bord d'un
vélo électrique un projet pensé depuis
des mois qui mêle sport écologie et
solidarité
mathieu jean frau récolte des fonds pour
louer une petite fille de 6 ans atteinte
d'une maladie provoquant un fort
handicap physique et mental
reportage de bixente mais rien senti
stemann un moteur des rétroviseurs un
toit en panneaux solaires match
chanfreau assembler un vélo pas comme
les autres c'est un vélo à trois roues
que j'ai acheté d'occasion également que
j'ai électrifié avec une entreprise qui
dans le sud de la france qui s'appelle
déclic échos qui m'a bien aidé qui m'a
aidé aussi pour le tout la partie
support des panneaux et puis bah le test
je les fais il ya deux jours seulement
donc juste deux semaines avant de partir
encore un bolide qui servira à faire le
tour de la corse dès le 13 mai prochain
700 kilomètres en une semaine pour un
dénivelé global de 10000 m en attendant
son départ mathieu s'exerce à la
maîtrise de son nouveau vélo vélo
électrique m'a redonné goût à vélo m'a
remis en forme aujourd'hui je fais des
distance de 80 km en vtt que je faisais
pas avant
donc ça marche dans les deux sens en
fait on peut passer du vélo électrique
au vélo bio et du vélo bio à
l'électrique
une expédition pensait en novembre
dernier avec un ami dans laquelle il
manquait quelque chose
moi il me manquait une dimension un peu
humaine
dimensions utile à ce projet là et donc
j'ai parlé à nico que j'avais vraiment
envie d'essayer de trouver quelqu'un
pour compliquer en plus je suis aidé en
fait pas forcément une grosse
association un peu impersonnel mais
quelqu'un dans notre entourage notre
village et c'est un peu le hasard ou je
sais pas ça s'est passé un peu
naturellement deux jours après je
tombais sur un poste de sur facebook
2ème ligne mais qui est la maman d'une
petite fille polyhandicapée dans
jouars-pontchartrain temps un mot qui
est juste à côté
et donc j'ai pris contact tout de suite
et on s'est vu le lendemain et basse a
accroché mathieu a décidé d'utiliser son
projet pour médiatiser la maladie de lou
6 ans atteinte du syndrome de rett
c'est la maladie qui touche le plus de
petites filles en france le côté sportif
nous a tout de suite plu parce que nous
on est on est une famille de sportifs
on a été un petit peu bloquée par le
handicap de loups pour pouvoir faire
plein de choses et malgré son handicap
c'est vrai qu'on fait encore beaucoup de
sorties vélo donc en fait on accroche sa
poussette au vélo de ludovic la plupart
du temps une cagnotte participative a
été mise en place pour soutenir les
traitements rares et coûteux de loups
le premier palier à 2000 euros pour un
fauteuil permettant à louer une assise
confortable a été atteint maintenant la
cagnotte participative aide au
financement de l'école équithérapie un
ensemble de soins physiques et mentaux
par les chevaux c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi
l'information revient demain à 18h en
direct dans le 7-8 journal présenté par
grégory canale et d'ici là je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée
[Musique]